JoJo's Bizarre Adventure is one of
the most popular anime series around.
Fans especially love the villains, and rightly
so –- the rogues' gallery is as flamboyant
and fantastic as its heroes. But
which villains reign supreme?
We've ranked them from worst
to best, so let's take a look:
One of the many assassins dispatched by Dio Brando
to destroy the Star Crusaders in the third season,
J. Geil has a direct connection to
the heroes at the center of the story.
It's a dark one: He assaulted and
killed Jean Pierre Polnareff's sister,
Sherry. This makes him a more central part of the
story than one might expect of a minor villain.
There are two main characteristics that
make J. Geil stand out. The first is his
distinctive physiology: he has two right hands.
The second is his Stand, Hanged Man, a potent,
light-based power that can jump from
one reflective surface to another.
J. Geil makes wicked use of his abilities,
killing protagonist Jotaro Kujo's friend,
Mohammed Avdol, and nearly killing
Polnareff himself. Thankfully,
he is defeated thanks to quick thinking and
manipulation of his Stand by Noriaki Kakyoin.
Anjuro Katagiri is one of the creepiest Jojo bad
guys around. Appearing in Diamond Is Unbreakable,
he's a life-long criminal, convicted of robbery,
rape, and murder by the age of 12. He spent
the next 20 years in and out of prison,
eventually landing himself on death
row. Just before his execution,
a mysterious stranger shot him with a bow and
arrow, which granted him the Stand Aqua Necklace,
which enabled his escape. He proves a formidable
foe for Jotaro Kujo and Josuke Higashikata — until
they trick his Stand into being captured
and fuse the diabolical Angelo with a rock.
His depraved criminality knows no bounds, whether
he's killing children or biting the face off a
dog. His Stand Aqua Necklace, made entirely of
water, is able to evade detection by merging
with puddles and streams, change shape, and work
its way into the bodies of Angelo's victims,
either possessing or outright killing them from
within. It's a gruesome power in the hands of
a gruesome man who, fortunately, falls
in battle early on in the heroes' quest.
Daniel J. D'Arby, one of Dio's assassins,
is dispatched to defeat Jotaro Kujo.
While his stand, Osiris, allows him to steal
others' souls, he prefers to gamble for
them in games of chance — games he inevitably
attempts to fix. It's only thanks to Jotaro's
incredible ability to bluff in poker that
he's defeated and the souls he stole set free.
What makes D'Arby stand out, other than
his excellent taste in vests, is that,
unlike a lot of JoJo's Bizarre Adventure villains,
he isn't the type to be beaten in physical combat.
His suave intelligence allows him to steal
the souls of half the Stardust Crusaders team
and very nearly defeat Jotaro entirely.
He is, of course, bluffed into catatonia,
folding on four kings during a poker hand in
which the hero never once looks at his cards.
"I can't do it! I'm petrified! I'm
too terrified to say the words!"
First of all, Steely Dan gets major props for
his moniker, which is an overt reference to the
jazz-influenced 1970s rock group of the same name.
But it's Dan's Stand, The Lovers, that really puts
him over the top. Microscopic in size, it crawls
into its victim's ear and attaches itself to the
brain stem, where it uses its power to cause any
attack on Steely Dan to be reflected back to the
attacker, magnified. Oh, and it can also implant
Dio's flesh buds and murder its host from within.
JoJo's Bizarre Adventure really builds up
viewer animosity for Steely Dan during his brief
appearance in Stardust Crusaders. By using The
Lovers on Jotaro's grandfather, Joseph Joestar, he
holds our hero hostage, threatening to hurt him if
he doesn't obey Dan's bidding. Humiliated, beaten,
and forced to rob a jewelry store while the
villain gloats, Jotaro is eventually able to make
Steely Dan pay, once his companions manage to free
Joseph from The Lovers. All this buildup makes
Steely Dan's defeat one of the most satisfying
dispatches of a bad guy in the show's entire run.
Some characters in JoJo's Bizarre Adventure
possess Stands so powerful and impressive,
they strike fear into the heart of anyone
who has to face them. Terunosuke Miyamoto
is not one of those characters. Even this
minor villain from Diamond Is Unbreakable
admits that his Enigma power, which
allows him to turn someone into paper
if he can identify the mannerisms that
show they're afraid, is kind of lame.
What makes this particular baddie so impressive,
though, is the mileage he manages to get out
of such an unimpressive Stand. When he
encounters Josuke and his companions,
he very quickly manages to learn their individual
expressions of fear, trapping the heroes in paper
form one at a time. Then, it's just a matter of
deploying a convenient paper shredder to create a
perilous situation that is only narrowly averted.
Thankfully, Josuke and his team are saved,
and they exact a particularly fitting vengeance,
trapping Miyamoto in the form of a book, which
the hero then donates to a library. He's not the
most powerful villain a Joestar has ever faced,
but there's no better example of making
evil lemonade out of lemons, Stand-wise.
Appearing in Stardust Crusaders, Hol Horse has the
mien of a cool gunslinger, and his Stand, Emperor,
is pretty awesome, taking the form of a pistol
with bullets he can redirect. However,, he's
one of the most ineffective and cowardly villains
in the long history of JoJo's Bizarre Adventure:
Hol Horse runs away the moment he lacks villainous
backup. Hired by Dio Brando to assassinate Jotaro
Kujo, he's several times a thorn in the side
of our heroes, but always ends up thwarted.
So, why is he not at the top of the list?
Well, there are villains who scare you,
and villains who amuse you, and Hol Horse
definitely falls into that latter category.
His foolishness and unwillingness to,
pardon the pun, take a stand without
backup leads to his plans falling through in
hilarious ways. Even his demise is ridiculous,
as his broken watch leads to him
messing up one of Boingo's prophecies,
firing Emperor into a pipe at the wrong
time and shooting himself instead of Jotaro.
"The gun is mightier than the
sword! Huh! Such a brilliant quote!"
The list of Passione members who take on Giorno
Giovanna and Bucciarati's crew in Golden Wind is
long, but none make quite as much of an impression
as this hot-headed, ice-wielding assassin.
His Stand, White Album, is not only named
after one of the best records of all time,
it's versatile and potent, and Ghiaccio knows how
to use it to deadly effect. It's simple, at root,
allowing the wielder to freeze anything he
touches. But when Ghiaccio deploys it to
do everything from ice skate to solidify the
moisture in the air, it proves a significant
challenge for Giorno to overcome. Oh, and it
also serves as impenetrable, full-body armor.
Of course, like any great power, White Album
comes with a weakness: A small air hole at the
back of the neck. You might not think that would
be of enough significance to be exploitable,
but it very much is. Fortunately for the good
guys, a conveniently placed splintered lamp post
impales Ghiaccio and saves their hides. The killer
doesn't go out without a fight, though, attempting
to freeze his own blood in order to stay alive
long enough to make one last-ditch attempt
at victory. It's short-lived, and a chilling
conclusion for Passione's most memorable enforcer.
A member of a powerful and ancient race of
superhuman beings known as the Pillar Men,
Kars is the main antagonist in the
second part of Battle Tendency.
He ticks a lot of the Big Bad boxes:
He's so evil he kills his own people,
he's super-powerful, and he has
insane goals of manipulating an
ancient artifact –- the Stone Mask, which he
creates in an effort to maximize the potential
of the Pillar Men's powers -– to become the
ultimate life form. Treacherous and relentless,
he wields considerable power in his quest to
complete the Stone Mask, including an effect
called Light Mode that creates chainsaw-esque
blades that can cut through solid stone.
What makes Kars really cool, however, is the fact
that he actually achieves his goal. That's right:
He really does manage to complete the Stone Mask
and don it to become the ultimate life form. It's
only through a stroke of desperate instinct that
Joseph Joestar is able to redirect one of Kars'
attacks in order to create a massive volcanic
eruption that launches the Pillar Man into space.
There, he freezes and drifts away from Earth,
doomed to forever float through the void.
Vanilla Ice's name is one of the more on-the-nose
musical references in JoJo's Bizarre Adventure,
but make no mistake — this guy means business.
His most impressive characteristic is his
slavish devotion to his boss, the vampire Dio
Brando. Let's face it, as a top-line villain,
you can't do much better than a henchman
who is literally willing to slice off his
own head to make you happy, as Vanilla Ice
does for Dio Brando in Stardust Crusaders.
He's immediately resurrected as a vampire and
goes on to viciously attack the Crusaders,
beating Iggy to death and nearly taking
out Polnareff, one piece at a time.
When he's not busy sacrificing his life or
engaging in animal cruelty, Vanilla Ice wields
the powerful Stand Cream, which, yes, is named
for the 1960s rock band featuring Eric Clapton.
Cream creates a sphere of void that swallows
its user, making him invincible and wiping out
anything it comes across. While it does have
the weakness of making Ice unable to see while
he's using it, Cream proves very potent, and it's
only thanks to Vanilla Ice's lack of experience
with his vampiric form that the Crusaders
are able to defeat him once and for all.
Really, just look at this guy. Even among
the mighty Pillar Men, his physique stands
out — especially since Wamuu has no problem
showing it off in a variety of poses.
If his body is impressive, however, it's his
heart that really sets him apart. While he's
indisputably a villain, he possesses a clear moral
code and a respect for the honor that comes with
battle. He's a man of his word, uninterested
in the immortality that motivates Kars and keen
on respecting the enemies who prove themselves
against him. He also refuses to harm children,
which really makes him stand out in the
world of JoJo's Bizarre Adventure villains.
Simply put, while Kars might be Battle Tendency's
biggest threat, Wamuu is its most interesting. He
uses his Divine Sandstorm power to defeat Joseph
Joestar, but accepts the hero's challenge of a
rematch a month later. Then, he faces Caesar
in a massively compelling fight that ends,
thanks once more to Divine Sandstorm, in the
hero's demise. His final battle with Joseph,
a lengthy and violent chariot race, is one
of the more exciting moments in the series.
The shadow Dio Brando casts over the events
of JoJo's Bizarre Adventure is huge: He's the
series' most important villain, the antagonist
for numerous generations of the Joestar family,
and quite possibly one of the nastiest bad guys in
anime. His list of transgressions prior to using
the Stone Mask to become an immortal vampire
is heinous enough, but things only get worse
once he comes into his power. Said power includes
eye lasers, healing abilities, a freezing touch,
and topping it all, his time-stopping Stand,
The World. Simply put, Dio Brando is bad news.
He's also the main villain in two separate JoJo's
Bizarre Adventure series, first in his attempt to
usurp the Joestar fortune in Phantom Blood, and
then in a reincarnated form in Stardust Crusaders.
Through it all, he displays a ruthlessness,
cunning, and bloodlust that sets him above and
beyond every other bad guy in the series, taking
countless lives and wreaking endless havoc. Oh,
and he's the reason the Joestars develop Stand
powers, which play a pivotal role in the show from
the moment of their introduction. Every JoJo's
Bizarre Adventure villain has his or her own
importance to the story as a whole, but for sheer
impact and evil, there's no beating Dio Brando.
"With my stand, I have the
ability to rule the world!
What can you do in the face
of such overwhelming power?"
There's no beating Yoshikage Kira for
villainy. Unlike other names mentioned here,
he has no ambition to take over the world or
achieve immortality. Ultimately, he just wants to
be left to his own devices — which include being
a serial killer and chopping off women's hands.
Yes, he's a twisted soul, which makes
the fact that he possesses one of the
most powerful Stands in the series all the
more horrifying. His explosive abilities,
all taking their name from Queen songs, allow
him to detonate his victims, either directly
in the case of Killer Queen, or remotely,
with Sheer Heart Attack and Bites the Dust.
There are certainly more flamboyant villains in
the JoJo's Bizarre Adventure pantheon, but it's
the juxtaposition of the mundane and the insane
that makes Yoshikage Kira one of the best around.
On the one hand, we spend time watching him live
a normal human life, taking walks in the park,
and being generally comprehensible. Then,
however, he indulges his most twisted tendencies,
unleashing Killer Queen in pursuit of his sadistic
desires. He shows us the kind of monster that
can exist under the most mundane of surfaces,
and that's why he's an unforgettable villain.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about
your favorite anime are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one.